you went to the met gala in New York
this week and this is I mean this is the
biggest fashion show of the year nuts I
mean half the people on my staff just
don't work that day you can see who wore
what net the Met Gala let's look at your
your outfit or what you were Michael
Kors you were drinking course alright it
was there was not a course to be seen
but Michael was all over me
yeah consensual yes so so that's what
you wore and how much thought went into
that outfit a lot but you don't get a
lot of choice so you go with the
designer and the designer sort of
chooses what you're gonna wear with your
stylist and there's like all this hubbub
and to do and there's a theme for the
Met Ball every year and what was the
theme this year heavenly bodies in the
Catholic Church the Catholic Church
that's exactly right
now so my look was inspired by so I'm
not gonna get this correct but I think
it's the third Sunday of Lent the clergy
wears pink to signify the coming joy it
might be the second I don't think that's
anything to do with what you're wearing
I honestly okay here's my question how
do people get invited to this thing I
was not invited why am I not invited to
the Met Gala I am absolutely sure you've
been invited you've never been no I've
no that was my first year invited on my
own and it was very very excited why am
I not seen as a fashion icon
that's a reasonable question you are a
fashion icon and clearly there was some
mistake in your invitation got lost in
the round you're the best liar I've ever
met you're you're like a chilling serial
killer he could lie and lie again let's
talk about some of the outfits if you
would please okay
for example Rihanna this is Rihanna yeah
right
she was wearing I believe for Maison
Margiela designed by John Galliano and I
love that I'm like a fashion critic
what's up Maison Margiela he's the
automa jela is an incredible design
house oh yeah that I've loved for ever
and now John Galliano is designing for
them and she's the first woman to ever
wear a Pope's hat I heard is that true
apparently I better than bad gallery I'm
certain that the the woman who cleans up
you know at the Pope's apartment once
saw his hat there and looked around he
has a papal apartment at the Vatican I'm
sure all the people that work there
yeah it really knows are you serious
right now are you he has no the papal
apartment yeah really yeah if you don't
make us rats they kick him out but no I
think anyone who comes in I think the
guy who's there to hook up a show to
tries it on like looks around and puts
the hat on it's like all right rescue
and you're a saint and all that so no I
think plenty of people just so you know
I don't think the wait that's the way it
works okay well I don't mind people come
over there he goes Ilana try on that
yeah that would be so great yeah he's
not in town right now you want to ride
the popemobile er okay so who are the
Katy Katy Perry wore wings and she came
into chair Harry ward giant wings yeah I
did see that i understood that okay
wings I understand wings I understand
the symbolism of wings and how it
connects to God different things
sometimes it's a designer they just
their latest collection is what you wear
and sometimes you go with a theme and
they kind of create something for you
yeah well I have a question specifically
about Jared Leto
let's show Jared Leto oh that's the way
he always dressed now wait a minute
I don't know he looks like Jesus if
Jesus became a rabbi
but definitely always dressed that way
it's very King Friday from mr. Rogers
yes yes I will take jared leto in
whatever he has on dressed as a pope or
a Jesus or a who yeah to girlfriend Wow
I don't know what I'm doing anymore
I found that upsetting that just well
Jared Leto just he can do whatever he
wants he lives the perfect life I want
to be clear you could do it too
I could not if I showed up dressed like
that at the Met Gala I would be beaten
with sticks they would distribute sticks
to the crowd and everyone would beat me
with them because I can't pull that [ __ ]
off and Jared Leto can that's what
walking the red carpet feels like
you